hoy se conmemora el Día Mundial de la
lucha contra el cáncer de mamas una
fecha para concientizar y sensibilizar
sobre la importancia de detectar Y
tratar esta enfermedad a tiempo según la
ome es el cáncer de seno representa el
16% de todos los cánceres en paciente
femeninos y es primera causa de muerte
en las mujeres en América Latina y el
Caribe la proporción de mujeres
afectadas por esta enfermedad antes de
los 50 años desde el 32% mucho mayor que
en América del Norte que tiene un 19%
según la organización Panamericana de la
salud Cuáles son los últimos avances
para su tratamiento pues se lo vamos a
preguntar a nuestra primera invitada del
día ella Sandra Díaz Sandra Díaz
coordinadora unidad funcional de mama y
tejidos blandos institutos Nacional de
cancerología Gracias Sandra por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de miércoles en
directo América de Francia 24 y también
está con nosotros nuestra periodista de
salud mar Romero salamar también
bienvenida por supuesto a este espacio
Gracias
doctora muchos Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos lo primero que queríamos Un
día como hoy donde damos cifras a veces
desesperanzadoras es decir este año ha
habido algo que celebrar digamos en lo
que respecta a los avances de la
investigación de tratamientos y también
de prevención alrededor del cáncer de
mama
Buenos días Pues acá estoy en la
consulta del Instituto volándome un
segundito para poder atenderlos
básicamente cáncer de mama es de los
tumores que tiene mayores avances en el
tratamiento
hay surgimiento de nuevos agentes de
quimioterapia y de nuevas terapias
biológicas
especialmente para tumores con biología
her2 y los triple negativos y los
tumores luminales hoy en día hay mejoría
a nivel mundial de las tasas de
mortalidad por cáncer y se deben en gran
medida dos razones uno es la detección
temprana con los programas organizados
de de tamización con mamografía y lo
segundo al tratamiento sistémico
ayudante por las nuevas moléculas
Entonces eso hace que los pacientes
terminen recibiendo varias líneas de
tratamiento y el cáncer vaya
convirtiéndose en una enfermedad Crónica
para algunos pacientes otros
desafortunadamente pues van a fallecer
como consecuencia de la enfermedad
Sandra sin duda lo acabas de decir la
prevención es el tema digamos más
importante no en la batalla contra el
cáncer de mama Cómo hacer una prevención
a tiempo como detectar este cáncer a
tiempo las mujeres que lo padecen no
para pues mejorar evidentemente en el
tratamiento y que no sea ya demasiado
tarde
el problema en cáncer de mama es que el
80% de las pasiones no tienen no tienen
factor de riesgo asociado hay un 5 al
10% que son de carácter heredero
familiar y hay algunos factores de
riesgo identificados pero algunos de
ellos no son modificables Entonces lo
importante es el diagnóstico temprano de
la enfermedad y asomaba al diagnóstico
temprano que la paciente tenga
tratamiento oportuno y todas las
estrategias de tratamiento el
tratamiento del cáncer de mama es
multidisciplinario incluye cirugía con
el cirujano de mama
agentes de quimioterapia monoterapia o
terapias biológicas como los mencioné
previamente que son administradas por el
oncólogo clínico y algunas por el
cirujano de mama la radioterapia Pero lo
importante es que la mujer tenga hábitos
de vida saludable peso adecuado dieta
saludable hacer ejercicio el disminuir
el consumo de alcohol y cigarrillo
y realizarse su autoexamen mensual
obviamente y acudir de manera inmediata
si detecta alguna normalidad al examen
clínico de la mama realizarse su
mamografía de tamización que hay unas
normas para cada país en cuanto al
inicio de dicha prueba realizarse la
mamografía
reclamar el resultado de chamamografía y
consultar al médico sí aparece alguna
normalidad en dicho examen para poder
realizar la toma de biopsia Y si aquella
biopsia es positiva pues iniciar
tratamiento
doctora Díaz sabemos que en los próximos
años y especialmente en la región
americana y latinoamericana se prevé que
el cáncer de mama crezca no que esta
prevalencia vaya en aumento cada vez más
a eso queríamos preguntarle por qué qué
podemos hacer también para tratar de
evitar que crezcan tanto estas cifras O
al menos para prepararnos y también para
preparar nuestros sistemas de salud para
hacerle frente a este desafío
cáncer de mama Es según datos de
globocan 2020 cáncer de mama es el
primero en incidencia en el mundo en las
mujeres y en países en Vía de desarrollo
como Colombia y es el primero en
mortalidad pero en países
desarrollados la primera causa de
mortalidad son otros tipos de
creo que perdimos la comunicación con la
doctora díazmar Pues evidentemente
mientras Tratamos de recuperar la
información pues rescatar un poco lo que
estaba diciendo no la prevención
evidentemente y pues estar muy atentos
las mujeres no sobre todo para esta
autodetección de cualquier anomalía en
el seno doctora ya estamos con usted
nuevamente
sí les decía que pues cáncer de mama es
el primero en incidencia en el mundo en
nuestro país también y eso se debe a que
hay cambio cambios en los hábitos de
vida de las mujeres se sabe que en áreas
urbanas es donde mayor se concentra la
incidencia de cáncer de mama y Estos son
debidos a cambios en la dieta y aún
mayor digamos obesidad de los pacientes
Yo pienso que también el hecho y la
introducción de los programas de
tamización con mamografía hecho que se
diagnostiquen de manera mucho más
temprana la enfermedad es así como en
Estados Unidos el 25-30% de los
pacientes son diagnosticados con
carcinoma insípido que tiene un
excelente pronóstico Entonces yo pienso
que hay que hacer énfasis en la
detección temprana con el uso de las
pruebas de tamización que son autoexamen
examen clínico de la mama y mamografía
de tamización en la respuesta adecuada
del sistema para tomar exámenes
adicionales ecografía
biopsias resonancias en algunos casos el
inicio temprano del tratamiento y que el
paciente realice todos los tratamientos
que son O sea no solamente es operarse
hay que recibir la radio hay que recibir
quimioterapia hay que recibir
hormonoterapia etcétera